all right well it's time for this week's
pet project amy lee joins us from the
nspca and she brought along someone who
needs a safe and caring home a dog named
coco hi coco
hi tell us a little bit about coco
okay so he's he's obviously i've got a
treat in my hand obviously so he is very
focused on that but coco is such a sweet
11 year old senior he is so deserving of
a loving home he you know this this
little guy um you know should be in a
loving home and is during his golden
years right i mean he's so sweet he
loves other little dogs so if you've got
a mellow home um you know even with
other small dogs that you could bring to
the shelter for meet and greet um if you
decide to take coca home i mean just
look at this little love bug he's so
sweet he's so spunky and uh you know
he's he's absolutely the best he just
loves treats obviously
who doesn't right he's so cute
i just want to talk in a baby voice to
any cute dog i can't help it
and is coco good with small children or
is there anything else that we know
about coco or that people should be
aware of if they're interested in
adopting
absolutely so coco is only nine pounds
so he's little so would would be ideal
to have older children that know how to
be mindful around small dogs um again
having another small dog that's friendly
in the home that's kind of mellow and
and likes to play would be great and
ideal for him um he does require
sunscreen so we'll send you home with a
special sunscreen if he's going to be in
the sun for a long period of time but
you know just just your typical senior
he's prone to a few lumps and bumps but
you know as an 11 year old dog you know
as they get older it's just something to
expect as as they're you know senior i
love that coco cares about his skin care
that's very important here in las vegas
and before we wrap up is there anything
else going on with the nspca that we
should know about
oh my gosh we have so much going on
we've got our neon dog walk happening on
october 9th and we've got our calendar
contest happening now so you can go off
to our website and vote for your
favorite pet um we're going to be
relocating so if you just stay tuned
follow us on social media visit our
website we've got a lot going on great
well thank you so much and if you're
interested in adopting a pet just go to
nevadaspca.org or call them directly at
702-873-7722 we'll be right back